[Musique]
c'est sous l'œil aguéri du colonel
d'artillerie jean-juselin Mingard
fondateur du lycée de lîlebourbon que
les élèves de 4e scrutent fébrilement le
tableau d'affichage pour cette rentrée
2016-207 après une longue période de
vacances et des retrouvailles
chaleureuses dans la cour du collège
l'heure est donc de savoir si son ou sa
meilleure amie sera dans la même classe
que nous ce qui sembleêtre une
motivation pour certains élèves krishna
est heureuse elle retrouve ses
meilleures copines
Meille
est travailler et c'est le cadre posé
par le principal nouvellement nommé au
collège Bourbon un accueil particulier
pour cette nouvelle année dans cet
établissement qui accueille plus de 800
élèves bonjour à tous
donc je vous trouve en pleine forme bien
reposé disposé à bien tr
le collège de Bourbon nous attendons
donc environ 820 élèves pour un effectif
d'encadrement d'environ 70 à 75
enseignants une quinzaine d'assistants
d'éducation pour la surveillance et
l'aide au devoir pour pour les
élèves en terme de préparation de la
rentrée bien j'ai eu la chance d'avoir
un adjoint qui a préparé donc les
emplois du temps et le déroulement de la
journée peut débuter c'est la principal
d'éducation qui fait l'appel avant que
chaque élève rejoigne le professeur
principal et se dirige vers sa classe un
premier contact important où le cadre
pédagogique et les règles seront posées
pour permettre une année scolaire dans
les meilleures conditions de 8h à 10h
c'était les 5e de 10h à midi donc ce
sont les 4è et cet après-midi ce sera
réservé aux élèves de 3e alors vous avez
pu voir là donc la rentrée des élèves de
4e ils sont très sympa comme tous les
élèves mais c'est vrai que la 4e c'est
l'année je ne vais pas dire de tous les
dangers mais c'est l'année vraiment de
l'adolescence hein même si on peut avoir
de de grands AC d'au encore parfois
jusqu'au lycée mais c'est l'année la
plus difficile entre guillemets j'ai
deux deux messages à faire passer le
premier c'est le c'est le respect hein
on demande un respect absolu des
personnes et des biens de
l'établissement et puis la deième chose
c'est le travail voilà on peut on peut
accepter qu'un élève soit en difficulté
même on est là pour remédier aux
difficultés des élèves par contre que
élèv ne travaillent pas c'est quelque
chose qui qui a du mal à passer le
collège Bourbon qui se distingue sur des
projets exemplaires à l'image de la
participation de ses élèves aux
commémoration de la bataille de Verdin a
su instaurer un climat de confiance
entre les élèves leurs professeurs et
les parents l'année scolaire 2016-207
est lancé bonne rentrée à
tous
[Musique]